[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend in 1 33 millionen
kubikmeter gas pro tag das klingt
erstmal nach viel das ist aber viel
weniger als bisher und bisher war es
bereits sehr viel weniger als
normalerweise der russische
staatskonzern gazprom hat angekündigt
seine gaslieferungen nach deutschland
nochmals zu halbieren
ab übermorgen auf nur noch 20 prozent
der eigentlichen kapazität
offizieller grund die wartung einer
turbine die bundesregierung hält das für
vorgeschoben vielmehr werde versucht
deutschland zu erpressen
russlands präsident am gashahn bevor die
eilmeldung heute kam hatten besorgte
firmen und besorgte politik im süden
deutschlands noch darüber diskutiert was
zu tun ist für einen fall der kurz
darauf bereits eintrat aus stuttgart eva
schiller
wie schwer es im moment ist pläne zu
schmieden zeigt sich am gas gipfel in
baden württemberg die bundesnetzagentur
ist per video zugeschaltet doch schon
stunden später soll sich ihre prognose
als überholt erweisen gazprom verkündet
eine senkung der liefermenge durch nord
stream 1 von 40 auf 20 prozent begründet
das mit reparaturen dazu das
wirtschaftsministerium schmallippig wir
haben die ankündigung zur kenntnis
genommen es gibt nach unseren
informationen keinen technischen grund
für eine reduktion der lieferungen
irgendwas tun gegen russische
machtspiele gegen die machtlosigkeit die
idee des gipfels passt zu diesem tag
zwar ist für die gas verteilung im
notfall der bund zuständig aber sparen
müssen kommunen wirtschaft und
verbraucher mindestens 20% kleinvieh
macht auch mist
wenn man zwei minuten duscht statt
11 dann spart man halt 80 prozent der
energie die für die man fürs duschen
braucht ein und wenn das millionen
machen hat das einfach eine richtige
messbaren wichtigen effekt jetzt kommt
halt wirklich auf jeden an
zur diskussion um atomkraft will sich
deutschlands drittgrößter
energieversorger enbw nicht äußern aber
während stuttgart spar ideen sammelt
bröckelt in berlin bei spd und grünen
der widerstand was eine
laufzeitverlängerung der atomkraftwerke
angeht
es ist aber auch klar dass die regierung
in dieser neuen lage in der wir uns
befinden
vollkommen ideologiefrei und
ergebnisoffen schaut was vernünftig und
angemessen ist wenn es dazu kommt dafür
eine wirkliche notsituation haben dass
krankenhäuser nicht mehr arbeiten können
wenn eine solche notsituation eintritt
dann müssen wir darüber reden was mit
den brennstäben ist ein neuer stresstest
soll entscheiden helfen so oder so dass
gas problem bleibt in brüssel wirbt
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
morgen bei den energieministern für
ihren plan 15 prozent des gasverbrauchs
soll jedes land einsparen
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass alle
mitgliedstaaten die nachfrage drosseln
dass alle mehr speichern und mit
denjenigen mitgliedern teilen die
stärker betroffen sind energie
solidarität ist ein grundprinzip unserer
europäischen verträge das sehen offenbar
nicht alle so erst rückten spanien und
portugal vom ein sparziel ab dann
frankreich und polen stellt sich die
frage ob das prinzip freiwilligkeit beim
gas sparen ausreicht um russland
gemeinsam etwas entgegenzusetzen
noch mal weniger gas aus russland also
deutlich weniger gas wie viel grund zur
besorgnis ist da tatsächlich angebracht
zur einordnung ist jens süden bei uns
wirtschaftsprofessor an der uni
düsseldorf er berät unternehmen und auch
die bundesregierung in sachen
energiewirtschaft unter anderem
professor guten abend und
haben nur noch 20 prozent der kapazität
jetzt also in nord stream 1 was hat das
für folgen
es wird es deutlich schwieriger machen
die vorgaben was den gas füllstand
angeht jetzt noch zu erreichen wir
stehen momentan bei 65 prozent zum
ersten november wollen wir 90 prozent
haben damit wir mit gut gefüllten
speichern dann in den winter starten das
wird jetzt deutlich schwieriger und
teurer zu erreichen sein aber dann fehlt
im winter ja auch die gas zuströme aus
russland dh der speicher wird sich dann
auch schneller leben als uns das lieb
ist und wenn wir pech haben also wir
einen kalten winter bekommen und wenn
sich vor allem beim gasverbrauch zu
wenig tut dann droht eben dass wir
irgendwann im februar märz beim
schweizer in der nähe von null rutschen
und wer gegebenenfalls in die gasmenge
lage kommen also rationieren müssten und
die industrie tatsächlich
produktionsstilllegungen hinlegen
müssten das ist die bittere realität mal
angenommen es bleibt jetzt bei diesen 20
das ist ja auch nicht ausgemacht kann
auf null gehen kann auch wieder hoch
gehen wie lange würden wir diese 20
prozent durchhalten
wir würden die schon durchhalten wenn
tatsächlich etwas beim privaten und
industriellen gasverbrauch passiert wir
müssen dort gut 20 prozent einsparen es
ist schon einiges passiert bei der
industrie bei den privaten haushalten zu
wenig dort wird bislang nur etwa fünf
prozent gegenüber dem vorjahr eingespart
es muss deutlich mehr werden wenn das
gelingt dann kennen wir auch mit diesem
20 prozent gas zu strom aus russland
durch den winter und hätten die chance
mit einem blauen auge davon zu kommen
aber es geht jetzt eben wirklich darum
dass diese einsparungen ganz schnell auf
den weg gebracht werden so dass sie
bereits in jetzt kommenden winter ab
oktober auch wirklich greifen
einsparungen da greift natürlich auch
die das preissystem der preisdruck wir
sehen ihnen ja jetzt schon auch wenn wir
ihn tatsächlich häufig noch gar nicht so
wirklich spüren was erwarten sie für die
preise jetzt aufgrund der ereignisse
heute
die großhandelspreise sind heute im
laufe des tages um nochmal zehn prozent
angestiegen man muss jetzt beobachten
wie es weitergeht aber die eigentliche
problematik liegt bei den
endkundenpreisen also wer ein neukunde
ist und heute einen neuen vertrag für
gas abschließt der muss jetzt etwa 26
cent für die kilowattstunde zahlen das
ist viermal so viel wie noch anfang mit
den letzten jahres das problem ist viele
kunden zahlen noch diese alten preise
viele kunden zahlen noch sechs sieben
acht cent bei denen ist also die krise
noch gar nicht angekommen und da ist die
große gefahr dass dann eben im winter zu
wenig einfach eingespart wird deswegen
wäre es jetzt ganz zentral dass diese
preisanpassung die bei allen sowieso
kommen werde die gaspreise werden im
jahr 2023 bei allen kundinnen und kunden
was sie steigen dass das jetzt aber
frühzeitig passiert dass die menschen
sich noch vor dem winter darauf
einstellen können und das kombinieren
mit entlastungs paketen für
einkommensschwache haushalte wo es echt
an die substanz geht das müsste aus
meiner sicht dieses paket müsse aus
meiner sicht noch vor beginn der
heizsaison also vor oktober dringend auf
die welt gebracht werden jens-uwe com
herr professor herzlichen dank auch
heute wieder für diese kurze knappe
analyse der lage vielen dank
atomkraft nein danke das war mal das
gründungs motto der heutigen
regierungspartei die grünen raus aus der
atomkraft war erklärte politik der cdu
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel nach der
reaktorkatastrophe von fukushima das
wirkt angesichts von energiekrise und
gasknappheit plötzlich sehr lange her
der cdu oppositionsführer zeigt sich
mittlerweile überzeugt am ende dieses
jahres werde die laufzeit der drei noch
verbliebenen akw in deutschland
verlängert und selbst bei den grünen
gibt es erste stimmen die sich zumindest
einen sogenannten streck betrieb
vorstellen könnten streck betrieb das
klingt nach mangelsituation und notfall
lage was das genau bedeutet erklärt
oliver reichert
[Musik]
die noch aktiven atomkraftwerke sind das
kernkraftwerk emsland von rwe das werk
neckarwestheim 2 von enbw und das akw
isar 2 von e.on sie produzieren und
sechs prozent des stroms in deutschland
die gaskraftwerke hierzulande die von
derzeit rund 13 prozent der elektrischen
energie
für einen sogenannten streck betrieb
müsste das atomgesetz geändert werden
denn bisher heißt es hier die
berechtigung zum leistungsbetrieb
erlischt mit ablauf des 31
dezember 2022
im streck betrieb würde man die in den
drei akw vorhandenen brennelemente
einfach weiter nutzen das setzt voraus
dass sie jeweils noch genug und
verbrauchtes uran enthalten man geht von
einem strick betrieb von einigen monaten
aus etwa bis ins frühjahr 2000 23
die drei betreiber der kernkraftwerke
haben sich jahrelang auf ein ende der
stromproduktion zum 31 dezember 2022
eingerichtet für einen streik betrieb
bräuchten sie zusätzlich mitarbeiter
außerdem haben sie für den atomausstieg
schadenersatz bekommen von dem sie
ungern etwas hergeben wollen
eines dieser atomkraftwerke steht in
baden württemberg neckarwestheim 2
ministerpräsident ist winfried
kretschmann von den grünen herr
ministerpräsident guten abend
guten abend herr sievers jetzt ist heute
bereits der fall eingetreten für den sie
ja vorbeugen wollen russland drosselt
weiter muss angesichts dieser lage die
kernenergie jetzt zumindest
vorübergehend weitermachen in
deutschland
es war ja gerade in eine stresstests
geprüft
ob das notwendig ist um die stabilität
der netze auch wenn es viele ausfälle
gibt etwa im
import nicht zum beispiel von den
atomkraftwerken in frankreich stehen ja
viele still dass man jetzt alles genau
sehr
dich geprüft ob das notwendig ist so man
dann andere fragen wie die der
sicherheitsarchitektur zurückstellen
muss jetzt gab es ja so einer prüfung
bereits im frühjahr damals kamen
wirtschafts und umweltministerium beide
grün geführt zum ergebnis ein
weiterbetrieb bringe nichts jetzt also
die von ihnen angesprochene neue prüfung
erwarten sie da ein anderes ergebnis
das weiß ich nicht ich meine macht ja
einen stresstest um damit ergebnisse zu
haben und dann fällt man der
entscheidung das ist ein vernünftiger
weg vorher um spekulieren halte jetzt
nicht für so vernünftig jetzt gibt es ja
leute die sagen so ein stresstest ist
auch die gelegenheit für die grünen da
eine 180 grad wende hin zu bekommen
atomkraft nein danke das ist ja immerhin
so etwas wie das gründungs motto ihrer
partei
ich meine davon werden wir auch nicht
abrücken
ich sehe auch gar niemand in der
bundesrepublik deutschland außer der afg
die wieder zurück zur atomkraft will es
geht ja nur um ein zeitlich begrenzte
eventuelle verlängerung von noch laufen
atomkraftwerken und das werden wir sehr
nüchtern und rational prüfen und
entscheiden wie erklären sie den
menschen dass in der derzeitigen
situation er die kohle weitermachen darf
als die atomkraft
war das einfach sehr viel einfacher ist
kohlekraftwerke haben wir die gehen
schon aus der reserve raus da ist jetzt
eher das problem
wir brauchen zum beispiel dafür in baden
württemberg zwei millionen zusätzlich
kohle die kann jetzt im moment nicht
ordentlich transportiert werden wenigen
wegen des niedrig standes der flüsse
also man sieht das ist auch das ist
schon schwierig aber atomkraftwerke ist
jetzt keine stereoanlage die mifare
grabmal aus oder anschalten kann das
sind sehr schwierige komplexe fragen und
die müssen einfach sorgfältig geprüft
werden und im moment es ist einfach
einfacher und nur dadurch lösbar das
problem indem man öl und kohle
kraftwerke wieder in betrieb nimmt jetzt
gibt's noch einen anderen aspekt des
ganzen herr kretschmann sie sind ja
politprofi wenn sie jetzt bleiben bei
einer klaren ablehnung von verlängerten
atomkraft laufzeiten bei den grünen dann
im herbst
sagen sie keine klare ablehnung im
moment ist jetzt ja die parteilinie
gesagt
nein nein nein ich habe gesagt
weder die grünen noch sonst eine
demokratische partei will zurück zur
atomkraft in deutschland
es geht ja nur darum ob man sie jetzt
eine zeitlang weiter laufen lässt und
das wird ganz nüchtern sachlich geprüft
und je nachdem wie die prüfung auch
folgt tut man das eine oder lässt das
amt aber durch ihr doch sehr engagiertes
nein nein nein gerade eben kann ich
jetzt doch annehmen dass diese prüfung
am ende durchaus so ausfallen könnte
dass wir ende des jahres dann erstmal
zumindest weiter auf atomkraft auch
setzen
jetzt wird geprüft dann hat man ein
ergebnis und entscheidet und das warten
wir jetzt einfach ab das liegt ja in der
august vor es macht keinen sinn jetzt
darum zu spekulieren sie hatten heute
ein gipfel mit versorgern
energieversorgern mit vielen unternehmen
mit wirtschaftsverbänden mit kommunen
bei sich in stuttgart da ging es darum
was passiert wenn russland weiter
drosselt kaum war der gipfel vorbei trat
das ein mus land drosselt weiter ab
mittwoch wie es deutschland darauf
vorbereitet
daran sieht man wie richtig der gipfel
und sein zeitpunkt war wir müssen jetzt
darauf reagieren indem wir alle reserven
zum einsparungen zur effizienz nutzen
damit wir einfach möglichst wenig gas
verbrauchen weil dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit gemindert dass wir in
eine gas mangel lage kommen das ist
einfach der beitrag den wir live können
und wenn die schwarmintelligenz entsteht
dass betriebe das öffentliche verwaltung
jeder verbraucher einfach an der
schraube dreht und bei sich ein spart
dann können wir einfach das problem auf
jeden fall mindern vielleicht kommen wir
sogar ordentlich durch den winter das
wird sich dann zeigen
und da das ja auch die energie verteuert
ist es auch sinnvoll dass die
unternehmen trotzdem wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben in dem sie jetzt diese reserven
mobilisieren an einsparmöglichkeiten und
auch der privatverbraucher spart ja dann
energie und spart geld und das geld
benötigt er ja um die steigende
energiepreise wenigstens zum teil
kompensieren zu können also man hat in
jedem fall was davon wenn man das macht
ist der appell des baden
württembergischen ministerpräsidenten
winfried kretschmann hat gerade von
vielen dank für das gespräch
bitte schön
dass wir vor anderthalb stunden
aufgezeichnet haben so hanna du beginnst
jetzt mit der aktuellen entwicklung im
krieg gegen die ukraine in der ukraine
sind die ersten drei deutschen panzer
des typs gebhardt angekommen zusammen
mit mehreren zehntausend schuss munition
insgesamt hat die bundesregierung der
ukraine 15 flugabwehr panzer dieses typs
versprochen unterdessen hat sich auch
die fdp in die diskussionen rund um den
stockenden panzer ringtausch mit polen
eingeschaltet und fordert nun genauso
wie die grünen direkte lieferungen an
die ukraine in erwägung zu ziehen
bundesinnenminister in feser und
bundessozialminister heil sind in die
ukraine gereist und haben dort kiew und
das zerstört ihn besucht der
wiederaufbau des landes stand im fokus
der gespräche mit regierungsvertretern
außerdem soll laut feser die
zusammenarbeit bei der aufklärung von
russischen kriegsverbrechen verstärkt
werden im januar wurden erstmals seit
jahrzehnten mehrere todesurteile
vollstreckt die militärjunta ließ vier
männer hinrichten darunter zwei
prominente vertreter der demokratischen
opposition der vorwurf lautete
terrorismus
die bundesregierung und
menschenrechtsorganisationen
verurteilten die hinrichtungen aufs
schärfste das militär im januar hatte
sich im februar 2021 an die macht
geputscht seitdem herrscht in dem land
chaos und gewalt
in tunesien sind die wahlberechtigten
heute aufgerufen über eine neue
umstrittene verfassung abzustimmen sie
hat mehr befugnisse für das
staatsoberhaupt zum ziel
angestoßen wurde das referendum vom
amtierenden präsidenten setzen sollte er
die abstimmung gewinnen könnte er unter
anderem regierungen ohne
parlamentsbeteiligung ernennen oder
entlassen gegen die neue verfassung
demonstrierten in den vergangenen tagen
tausende tunesier sie befürchten dass
das land zu einem autoritären
regierungssystem zurückkehren könnte
der papst bittet um entschuldigung für
das was institutionen seiner kirche
menschen angetan haben wieder einmal
diesmal in kanada dort mussten bis in
die 1990 er jahre insgesamt rund
150.000 kinder der indigenen bevölkerung
vom staat finanzierte christliche
schulen besuchen wurden von ihren
familien getrennt und von ihrer kultur
und nicht nur das es gab viele fälle
roher gewalt sexueller missbrauch und
vernachlässigung
bereits vor jahren hatte eine kanadische
kommission den papst zu einer
entschuldigung direkt in kanada
aufgerufen erst nachdem letztes jahr die
sterblichen überreste von 200 kindern
auf dem grundstück einer früheren schule
in british columbia gefunden wurden hat
der vatikan wirklich mit der
vorbereitung begonnen und heute spricht
franziskus zu überlebenden und zu denen
die nicht fassen können was da geschehen
ist elmar theveßen berichtet
jerrys ellenbeck begrüßt den papst mit
einer weise die katholischen internaten
verboten
teil der kulturellen vernichtung der
ureinwohner kanadas er verspüre trauer
empörung und charme wird franziskus
später sie
erst will er auf dem friedhof beten der
zu einer der schulen gehörte die kreuze
der opfer klagen an
redmond meter tobin erinnert sich wie
priester die kinder im saint saens
internaten fortell boni aus peitschten
sie für ungehorsam auf einem
elektrischen stuhl bestraften
er war aus metall mit draht
angeschlossen wir sollten ihn festhalten
und dann schalteten sie den strom ein
wir waren 67 jahre
in den katholischen internaten kanadas
wurden über 100 jahre bis 1996 die
kinder der indigenen völker umerzogen
ihrer kultur beraubt misshandelt
missbraucht tausende staaten victoria
macintosh hat die hölle auf erden erlebt
ihre eltern wurden gezwungen sie mit
vier jahren ins internet zu bringen wo
nun den priester nachts mädchen zu
führen er missbrauchte mich auf eine art
die kein kind je durchleiden sollte
china wo
der kreis gilt den ureinwohnern als
symbol der schöpfung und der ewigkeit
hier übernimmt der papst dem weise an
der anführer der ältesten der indigenen
völker die verantwortung für die taten
die die katholische kirche verübt und so
lange vertuschte
geht die sage voller scham und
unmissverständlich ich bitte demütig um
vergebung für das böse das von so vielen
christen an indigenen verübt wurde
die wunden sollen heim aber die bitte um
vergebung allein reiche nicht sagt
franziskus
wichtiger teil des prozesses ist auch
eine ernsthafte suche nach der wahrheit
über das geschehen
jerry turnier noch einmal die weise zur
erinnerung an die opfer und als dank
dass der papst hilfe und aufklärung
verspricht dann geschieht etwas
ungeplantes
sie singt voller schmerz die kanadische
hymne in der sprache des volkes der
klinik immer noch sind täter katholische
priester auf freiem fuß trotz des leids
das so vielen antaten
indigene gruppen in kanada erwarten
jetzt mehr als worte sie wollen zugang
zu den archiven der kirche um mehr über
das schicksal der kinder zu erfahren die
aus kirchlichen schulen nie mehr nach
hause kam
jetzt in der sendung noch mal du hanna
mit etwas ganz anderem nämlich eine
hiobsbotschaft für die lufthansa
passagiere christian mal wieder
nachrichten für flugreisende die gar
nicht gut sind mitten in der urlaubszeit
hat die gewerkschaft verdi zu
warnstreiks bei der lufthansa aufgerufen
das bodenpersonal will für einen tag die
arbeit niederlegen und zwar von mittwoch
bis donnerstag morgen warum genau jetzt
das fragen sich viele die in den urlaub
fliegen wollen stephanie beckert waffe
die gründe ja das ist wirklich bitter
für alle die ihren urlaubsflug mitte der
woche geplant haben immerhin spart die
gewerkschaft ver di das wochenende aus
uns wäre das chaos wohl noch größer
nächste woche wird ihm weiter verhandelt
und verdi nutzt wohl offensichtlich die
gelegenheit um noch mal druck auszuüben
9,5 prozent mehr gehalt so lautet die
gewerkschaftsforderung und ein
stundenlohn von mindestens 13 euro um
vor allem die unteren lohngruppen zu
stärken lufthansa lehnt die forderung ab
und verweist auf hohe energiekosten und
die wirtschaftliche unsicherheit laut
verdi geben die beschäftigten jedoch
auch nach dem massiven stellenabbau
täglich ihr bestes um den flugverkehr
aufrecht zu erhalten doch den
beschäftigten gehe einfach die luft aus
sie erwarteten jetzt angesichts hoher
inflation einfach ein starkes signal
dass uns auch noch über die möglichen
auswirkungen des streiks sprechen worauf
müssen sich reisende einstellen also
passagiere müssen sich darauf einstellen
dass die abläufe an deutschen flughäfen
bis donnerstag empfindlich gestört sein
dürften denn das lufthansa bodenpersonal
ist so ziemlich für alles zuständig
nicht nur für die passagier- und
gepäckabfertigung sowie wartung der
maschinen das bodenpersonal verantwortet
auch das herausschieben der maschinen
aus der parkposition in richtung
startbahn am airport düsseldorf erledigt
eine lufthansa-tochter rund drei viertel
dieser manöver mittwoch sind dort allein
430 flugbewegungen mit fast 60.000
passagieren geplant kann man sich
vorstellen was da los ist deshalb
sollten sich fluggäste unbedingt bei
ihrer airline oder ihrem
reiseveranstalter über den aktuellen
stand ihres fluges informierten
dargestellt von ihr für diese
einschätzungen
in brandenburg ist im landkreis
elbe-elster aus einem wald und acker
brand ein großbrand geworden das feuer
breitete sich innerhalb kürzester zeit
auf rund 100 hektar aus für drei
ortsteile der stadt falkenberg elster
wurde die evakuierung angeordnet laut
amtlichen warnmeldung des bundesamts für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
soll sich auch die ortschaft marsdorf
auf eine mögliche evakuierung
vorbereiten betroffen sind mehrere
hundert menschen
am allerletzten tag der
leichtathletik-wm in eugene gab es
endlich die erste und auch einzige
goldmedaille für das deutsche team
weitspringerin malaika mi ham wo
verteidigte mit sieben meter 12 ihren wm
titel erfolgreich
für die deutschen athleten ist es
allerdings mit zwei medaillen insgesamt
das schlechteste abschneiden in der wm
geschichte
heute ist der fünfundzwanzigste juli sie
können sich für die nächsten tage schon
in den kalender schreiben
bayreuth das macht vieles einfacher denn
traditionell immer am 25 juli beginnen
die richard wagner festspiele
nach einigen corona verschiebungen in
diesem jahr mit fünf neu inszenierten
werken so vielen wie noch nie zuvor
eingeleitet heute abend von tristan und
isolde den berühmtesten weltflucht werk
der musikgeschichte sagt der regisseur
und ergänzt wenn eine zeit das bedürfnis
kennt der welt zu entfliehen dann ist
das unsere barbara lueg nimmt uns mit
ein bisschen gültigen sie heute wohl
auch ihm hier ruht russ der geliebte und
richard wagners gleich daneben liegt er
den sie an diesem premieren morgen am
grab mit grenzen ehren still berührt
voller hindern
diese überirdisch musik wenn ich an
passiver denke der glaube lebt die taube
schwebt ja dass man selbst auch anfängt
so ein bisschen zu schweben
was für eine turbulente probenzeit war
das hier zuletzt noch zusätzlich
erschüttert durch sexismus vorwürfen die
festspielleiterin katharina wagner nun
gründlich aufklären will
auch corona beutelte den betrieb sänger
absagen dirigentenwechsel aber er ist
qualys lichter steven gold heldentenor
kraftpaket wir treffen ihn in einer
kurzen pause seines festspiel marathons
denn gold sind gleich drei wuchtige
titel partien wie er das alles schaffen
will
ich weiß nicht eigentlich weil ich habe
das noch nicht geschafft aber
aber ich glaube das ist es ist es nur
ein kondition erfordert
[Musik]
heute zur premiere sind er neben
catherine foster als isolde den tristan
beide rollen hochkomplex und stimmlich
extrem fordernd
[Musik]
ich treffe nicht so viele andere leute
ich gar nicht raus zum kaffeetrinken mit
anderer ich für mich diese fokus dieser
konzentration dass ich gebrauche mit
dieser riesen party
fünf premieren gibt es diesmal
unterschreiten die damen und herren zum
auftakt am nachmittag in drückender
hitze ins nicht klimatisierte
festspielhaus
es ist auch ein treffen alter bekannter
die gleich gemeinsam wagners tragischer
liebesgeschichte folgen werden
in dieser neue inszenierung wird aus der
tragödie
eine wunderbare hommage an die ewige
liebe
[Musik]
auf den gräbern ursprünglich von tristan
und isolde wachsen zwei pflanzen die
sich verschlingen da ist doch alles
alles drin das
weiterleben der liebe durch alle zeiten
und wagner wagners tristan ist die musik
der unendlichkeit wie kein anderes mehr
und so verströmt der grüne hügel heute
etwas in die welt dass sich alle
brauchen können hoffnung und liebe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
oh ja jetzt haben wir uns von der welt
gelöst haben uns verloren im universum
mit tristan und isolde aber morgen
versprochen bringen wir sie hier wieder
zurück auf den boden der tatsachen im
heute-journal und
außerdem empfehlen wir ihnen noch das
heute-journal update gegen 23.50 mit
nacktem ihr in ein angenehm haben
[Musik]
guten abend was war das wieder heiß
heute keine 40 aber mindestens 38 grad
wenn sie mitten in der stadt wohnen
wissen sie die trockene die luft desto
heißer wird sie städtische hitze inseln
können 10 bis 15 grad wärmer sein als
ihr begrüntes umland deswegen ist es
wichtig dass regenwasser nicht einfach
in der kanalisation verschwindet sondern
in der stadt gehalten wird indem
versiegelte flächen aufgerissen was
haben begrünt und dächer bepflanzt
werden all das kühlt carla hauswände
können sich bis 60 grad aufheizen
begrünte nur bis 30 grad
immer noch heiß genug und so ist es eine
gute nachricht für die meisten von ihnen
wahrscheinlich dass dieses tief die
große hitze aus mitteleuropa weg räumt
und wir morgen wahrscheinlich nirgendwo
mehr in deutschland die 30 grad haben
das geht einher mit kräftigen schauern
und gewittern die jetzt in der nacht von
west nach ost über uns hinweg ziehen und
in der zweiten nachthälfte können dass
in bayern zum teil sogar unwetter seien
die temperaturen sinken auf 19 grad in
der lausitz und am niederrhein bis zwölf
grad zum beispiel im nordhessischen
bergland und morgen bleibt es kühl an
den küsten mit nur so 18 bis 20 grad
sonst gibt es um die 25 grad am
vormittag als noch schauer und gewitter
hier im südosten geben sonst gibt es
einige schauer in norddeutschland und in
den nächsten tagen geht es sommerlich
und mit wenig regen weiter guten abend